hi I'm Jeremy Walker a YouTube developer
continuing our series with our gdes or
Google developer experts again these are
people that help us out with the YouTube
API s and we're going to talk a little
bit with Tim whittled today and he came
out all the way from London enjoy the
show and we're continuing our
conversation with our GES and we have
one of the veterans out here from London
Tim how was the flight fatty lung but ya
know ok yeah a little jet lag yeah I
know it's you me when I was when I
traveled across the pond I was a little
out of it myself but you've done great
so we were talking a little bit about
the data API which for you that don't
know is basically the API that lets you
do most everything you do on YouTube but
via the API I wanted to get your feeling
from the last year what was a feature
that that launched that you found the
most interesting so I think we the one
that immediately had the biggest
potential was the in-video programming
where you can specify particular
thumbnails particular links that you
want to come up to other videos at the
end of all the viewer videos oh yeah
that's that's a good feature for user
don't know it gives a nice little
overlay where you can feature video or
your channel was there I guess when
you're integrating with it was there any
surprises and so just how well it works
across devices compared to some of the
older annotations that's been out for a
while where it took a very long time for
them to starts work on mobile and and on
different platforms this just seems to
work very cleanly yes yeah and they yeah
that's true so for you don't know in the
UI you can create free form annotations
where you can put them wherever you want
but like you said those weren't
supported across every device so so we
covered the surprises do you have any
feature requests or anything you'd like
to see in that API then um so I'd love
to see that widen more and enable some
of the other uses for the freeform
annotations to
and my my kind of favorite one is the
selector an interactive video story
where you can select your your next
steps to kind of continue the narrative
like those a skip to page 130 yeah yeah
pick your poison I definitely know what
you're talking about okay well great
thanks for coming out and for all the
support we really appreciated and for
the audience please join us with the
interview with the rest of our experts
thank you